welcome into this video I'm playing
Jacques oneself from Argentina and
playing b6 the English Defence for some
reason somewhat statuary graphic here we
add okay we got a position with the
Dutch flavor got in f5 and I can take
now I play Knightly form that looks like
a nice position occupying the central
outpost okay long castles hmm okay I'll
play d 6 maybe he can play 25 now it's
not going for that d 5 maybe take so i
can take with the pawn maybe queen take
the c5 now you can play 95 for a porn
sec but this is not really dangerous i
believe okay maybe preparing 92 where i
want to i want to make sure that i can
play e5 at the right moment yeah here i
can take integrity to now i think i can
really take
I have bishop every year the temple and
then Knight f6 coming can I manage to
yet get to this Bishop traded it should
be really okay yeah just g6 I know I
don't want to weaken the structure so
we'll get seven is probably the better
choice okay interesting i have g7
covered how do I proceed now in the
center interesting I could go no
probably not leather just play evade the
FR were probably yeah we probably open
in any case you know just a 5v5 is the
most logical move really blocking the
center interesting
hmm yeah there's some pressure on g7 oh
and darling
you at the moment I can always recapture
with the Queen maybe let's close let's
close the center okay and I need to I
need to unpin I wonder if Queen d-sub
doesn't move Bishop takes roped a group
g7 countries augmented King takes you
something at the end playing with two
rooks against the Queen it's probably
not bad for me but not clear how good it
is
okay come on let's provoke that i'm not
i'm not really sure but it shouldn't be
bad for me really okay and I'm
threatening to just move the night away
ideally to age five and it basically
forces bishop f6 I guess maybe Bishop h6
but I guess taking on f6 taking on g7
assam was fast
what do I know yeah I was just thinking
okay I'll go back and now I'm what
exactly is why its attack I've rook F
too young even here I forgave to or not
okay to Bishop g7 I don't really see a
mate coming
I don't see a mate coming
one minute 30 that's not good my idea is
to get one pair of rooks exchanged or
get the Queen to f3 a 2 D 3 if you go
somewhere outside look at one and trade
one pair of rooks that seems desirable
and Queen d300 this is away from the
Kings side yeah I really thought this
wasn't possible did I miscalculate
probably check yeah I saw that and I
thought well this is yeah but a gent I'm
having so much more material is
even--look f1 late resign yeah okay
thankfully it wasn't working yeah I
don't really think this was a good porn
sec I mean the G file is nice but I get
rid of this i get rid of this this
bishop on d3 and i don't think this is
enough why white has some compensation
but it's not sufficient i believe he
probably should play something a bit
more quiet not too naughty form here i
should have played night h5 immediately
even pre-empting the Bishop g5 more
night h5 would have been stronger right
here now that's that's just just a
strong i get to f41 invade here and in
some way like that this for example
that's nice for black young I allowed
this Bishop g5 move yeah the computer
now wants to take on d4 and play c5
King yeah but this I don't think this is
too bad yeah yeah this is what I was
thinking check but at the end check the
roofs are just wrong like a threatening
to invade directly and the Sheikh he is
probably totally in totally fatal
already yeah something like that it's
not very nice the rooks an invading and
they have a safe square on h6 for the
king yeah and here why it simply has
nothing for the pawn okay Bishop f7 was
done but something like this maybe Queen
f7 and after this I have to go check
yeah black as a pawn up it's as simple
as that okay thanks for watching